russia's main aerospace exhibition the
max aviation salon
opens its doors for the 15th time with
many air shows getting cancelled because
of the pandemic
max has become the highlight of the
world aviation calendar
therefore hundreds of companies from 56
countries are participating
presenting their latest developments one
of the most anticipated debuts of max
is a new fighter jet set to take to the
skies in 2023
it's called the trackmate this is a
fifth generation supersonic aircraft
with a single
spool turbojet engine it is a younger
brother of the seahorse
57 fighter jet but it is smaller lighter
cheaper in terms of production and
maintenance
but it is stealthy it has internal
weapons base
and a very impressive payload the suhoi
company and the roster
call it a plane with an architecture
meaning that potential buyers
international buyers in particular will
be able to order a plane
they need for their particular purposes
according to the plane's designers they
are developing a two-seat and
unmanned versions of the jet
the plane is high speed it has a speed
of mach 1.8
which is about 1 900 kilometers per hour
it has powerful weapons it can carry
more than seven tons of payload
these are bombs missiles plus it will
have a cannon installed
so it's a fairly powerful aircraft and
at the same time it's light
it has one engine well that reduces the
range of its flight
but still another important achievement
of russian aircraft manufacturers
is the medium-haul ms-21 aircraft with
domestically produced pd-14
engines just a couple of years ago this
plane was flying with american pratt
and whitney engines and nowadays the
russian-made units
lift the plane into the sky during
demonstration flights
regarding the ms-21 we have the pratt
and whitney engine
you saw one such airplane flying with it
today and we have the russian pd-14
engine there will be two versions one
with russian components
and another with imported parts we do
this deliberately
so that customers especially foreign
ones have a choice
the super chat 100 is a regional short
and medium-haul passenger plane
that has already been on the market for
a decade and the demand is high
as three domestic airlines have signed
contracts
to buy hundreds of new planes making the
superchat one of the principal aircraft
for regional transportation
what we see today in chukovsky clearly
shows that russian aviation has great
potential for development
and our aircraft industry continues to
create new competitive aircraft
domestic airlines are receiving modern
super jet airliners
and in the near future the new ms-21
aircraft will enter service
it seems like russian engineers pay a
lot of attention to the development of
new types of engines
hybrid engines in particular powered by
electricity and hydrogen
electric engines are being developed to
power small planes and helicopters
all the new technologies will help
reduce harmful emissions
making flights more eco-friendly jules
pavalova rc